the trump administration brokers a
massive peace deal in the middle east
joe biden calls for a national mass
mandate and president trump opens a can
of worms on mail-in ballots i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben so you all remember that time when
barack obama won a nobel peace prize for
existing
like literally for breathing he won the
presidency of the united states in
late 2008 and by 2009 he was being
handed the nobel peace prize
for literally being a breathing human
being that was his only claim to fame
that was the only reason he was given
the nobel peace prize
even when he accepted it he was like i'm
not sure why i'm here what i do
again well i mean i am great i am kind
of a messianic figure but aside from
what i have no idea what i'm doing here
it was very very weird well what would
you say if there was a president
who brokered a peace deal between israel
and
one of its heretofore arab nation
enemies
and that peace deal provided the basis
for many other arab nations to start
making peace deals for normalization of
relations with israel
wouldn't that be considered like a big
win like a nobel prize
winning sort of thing i mean jimmy
carter won a nobel prize
based on brokering a peace deal between
egypt and israel
bill clinton was it was nominated for
nobel prize it was yitzchak caribbean
and arafat who won the nobel prize
bizarrely for the oslo
peace accords which turned out to be a
complete disaster area every single
american president tries to make some
sort of deal in the middle east but only
trump has been able to make a successful
deal in the middle east for the first
time
since like 1994 when jordan normalized
relations
with israel so it has been full on
almost three decades
since there was a solid peace deal in
the middle east and president trump
got it done he got it done because all
of the interests aligned now to be
completely fair
the reason the interests align is
because of president obama but because
president obama was a garbage president
who's terrible in the middle east
because obama decided that he was going
to forward the aspirations of the
iranian mullahs try to make them a
regional power he was going to
legitimize their nuclear program
over time he was going to try to open up
their economy he was going to look the
other way on their terrorism and their
attempts to
spread their power via regime changes
all over the middle east
because he did that a coalition of
forces formed against
the iranian rising power and that
included saudi arabia
egypt jordan the uae and yes israel it
turns out that the common interest
of all of those countries was in not
seeing the iranians rise to regional
power and so the uae looked at israel
and israel looked at the uae
and they said okay well we're on the
same page not only that the uae
and egypt and jordan and saudi arabia
all the countries in the region looked
at the palestinian government which is
allied itself with iran
and has for decades pursued at terrorism
in conjunction with the iranian regime
hamas which was funded by iran there's a
hezbollah which is funded by iran
they'll do palestinian islamic jihad
which is funded by iran and they said um
we don't want a state run by iran
another state
in the middle east run by iran that
threatens a country that is helping us
fight iran
and so they made clear what has always
been true
but which the the stupid conventional
wisdom on the middle east suggested was
false which is that the center of
gravity in the middle east was never
the israel arab conflict see there's
been this pervasive
idiotic notion that if you just solve
all the problems between israel and its
enemies then peace blossoms across the
middle east all of the sectarian
violence
that by the way has plagued the middle
east in far larger numbers all over the
middle east
than between israel and its neighbors
all of that would simply go away like
all the problems between
turkey and iraq would simply disappear
between turkey and the kurds that would
disappear all the problems
between syria and iran would simply go
away
all the problems between jordan and
palestinian
liberation organization all of that
would simply alleviate all the problems
between
iraq and kuwait everything would just go
away if he just focused in on the jews
this was the moral equivalent of
everybody saying that white woke
liberals in the united states if they
can only get things together they'll
heal all the problems in the united
states like no
that is none of that's real okay none of
that's real the notion
that if you force a peace on israel that
that was somehow going to alleviate all
the tensions in the middle east and
somehow all the sectarian violence was
going to go away
was always a chimera it was always an
act of western arrogance
it was always stupid and it's why the
conventional wisdom had suggested for
years that if
the united states moved its embassy in
israel from tel aviv the non-capital of
israel to jerusalem the capital of
israel
then war would break out everywhere and
then trump looked at it he said nah
that's not real he did it
and nothing happened nothing happened
because it turns out that there are many
interests in the middle east and very
few of them have to do with israel
it turns out their economic interest in
the middle east something the trump
administration recognized it turns out
their geopolitical interests in the
middle east
that simply trump the existence of
israel which is not going away and it
turns out that the foundation for any
piece in the middle east is a
recognition of reality
that the durable peace the durable peace
in in the middle east has to come with
recognition of realities on the ground
recognition like israel is not going
away
not only is israel not going away the
areas that israel controls
that have largely jewish populations are
not going to be seeded to the
palestinian authority recognition of the
of the reality the baseline reality
that the palestinian authority is in
fact a quasi-terror group that is
enthralled two terror groups
that is the dictatorship the
non-democratic dictatorship that the
transformation
of that terror dictatorship into a state
in control of weaponry and its own
borders would be a threat not only to
israel but to surrounding countries
like jordan and yes like lebanon and yes
like egypt
right that those are the baseline
realities on the ground the trump
administration recognized those baseline
realities on the ground
and arab nations now facing those
looming realities because iran was
rising and iran was continuing to fund
the palestinians and the problems in
syria and the problems in lebanon and
the problems in iraq
the rest of the middle east looked
around they said okay i guess we better
just recognize reality here and the
reality is it's better to be friends
with israel
than enemies with israel that's all that
happened here now the media are trying
to spin
the peace deal as though barack obama
created it
or that this was all about pressure on
israel because they have to keep fitting
a deal that completely goes against the
entire grain of what they've been
suggesting for years right that only a
left-wing
conciliatory submissive israeli
government was going to make peace
they have to keep pushing that line and
so thomas friedman in the new york times
has a bizarre piece today where he
argues that bibi netanyahu was somehow
pushed into a peace deal with the uae
which is just pure absurdity thomas
thomas friedman has his head so far up
his butt it is coming out his face again
he he's been wrong on everything to do
with the middle east so is everybody in
the obama administration they've been
wrong on everything
everything we'll get to that in just a
moment they're trying to claim credit
for a deal
that they themselves only made possible
because they got the middle east
completely wrong
meanwhile depriving the trump
administration of credit for the deal
when it was the trump administration
that did the
deal and shout out here to the assistant
to jared kushner avi berkowitz
i know avi avi was very very
instrumental in these talks
really avi did hard work to make this
happen it is a breakthrough peace
agreement everybody acknowledges it is a
breakthrough peace agreement and it will
be the basis
going forward for many more peace
agreements in the middle east as people
recognize
that basing peace on the complete
fiction that israel is going to
disappear or
that israel making territorial
concessions is what causes peace in the
first place
that that entire model is broken that
peace for peace
is the actual model here not land for
peace not israel giving up its own
safety and security
but peace for peace namely israel says
we're going to leave you alone and
everybody else says we're gonna leave
you alone to israel
and then they normalize economic
relations which by the way has always
been the basis for every durable peace
it's always been peace for peace it has
never been land for peace land for peace
is called blackmail
peace for peace is simply acknowledging
that the other person exists
and that has always been the predicate
for anything that remotely approaches a
durable piece so good for the trump
administration we're going to get into
more details here because this really is
a major thing and the media are going to
play it up for a moment and then they're
going to downplay it and pretend it was
obama which is insane
that's insane okay to pretend that
barack obama somehow facilitated
this peace deal through pressure on
israel like
five years ago and and hatred of bibi
netanyahu pure hatred of bibi netanyahu
it's totally crazy i mean it's nuts
we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that you are paying too much for
your cell phone bill so you can't afford
to be paying too much for your cell
phone bill right now you can't afford to
be paying too much for anything
right now so why would you be spending
tons of money on unlimited data that
you're not even using
right now who's your wireless providers
at att verizon t-mobile what if i told
you
that puretalk usa uses the exact same
network as one of those carriers same
towers
same coverage same quality but literally
costs you half
how do they make it so affordable well
no retail stores no low so low overhead
you're not funding their billion dollar
ad campaigns and you're only paying for
the data you need which means no
contract
no excessive fees you'll enjoy unlimited
talk text and two gigs of data all for
just 20 bucks a month
the average person using pure talk usa
is saving 400 bucks a year
on their wireless bill which is a lot of
money grab your mobile mobile phone
dial pounds at 250 and say ben shapiro
when you do
you get 250 bucks off any iphone wow
including the brand new iphone se
so you get a discount on an iphone se of
250 bucks when you go dial up pound 250
and say
ben shapiro again that is pound 250 say
keyword ben shapiro pound two five zero
say keyword ben shapiro to get that
special deal
from pure talk usa cut your cell phone
bill and you get a discount on
any iphone including the brand new
iphone se again pound 250
say keyword ben shapiro to get started
okay so the new york times reports this
israel and the united arab emirates
reached a landmark accord sealed by
president trump on thursday that could
presage a broader realignment in the
region as the two agree to full
normalization of relations in exchange
for israel's suspending annexation of
occupied west bank territory
okay so let's be clear right here bieber
netanyahu the israeli government
under the trump peace plan there was a
an opening for the israeli government to
basically declare that all
israeli territory meaning territories
that that were
largely populated by jews like afra like
areas outside green line israel green
line
is the line that was established
pre-1967 in 1967 israel wins the six day
war
and israel conquers the west bank
including east jerusalem
the so-called west bank of the jordan
river that's what it was called by
jordan it's actually judea and samaria
historically they conquered the gaza
strip and all of that okay and the
the basic idea is that there are a bunch
of jewish population centers
that are across the so-called green line
right including east jerusalem all the
historic sites
jerusalem by the way will never be
divided israel will never divide
jerusalem
nor should they because jerusalem when
it was controlled by jordan
was closed to people of a variety of
different religions including the jews
with that said there are a bunch of huge
population senators ephrath is one that
comes to mind but there are many many
others
and israel was thinking about simply
annexing those areas and saying those
belong to israel for
all time it wouldn't have made a big
legal difference honestly because other
nations that didn't want to recognize it
just would not have
nor would it have taken off the table
any of those areas as quote unquote land
swaps in future deals
it so it would have been kind of a
declaration only it wouldn't have meant
a whole hell of a lot it's not like
declaring
the golan heights sovereign israeli
territory because that
is in opposition to for example a syrian
claim
on the golan heights israel doing that
and being recognized by the united
states was pretty important it was
unclear
whether if israel quote unquote annex
the territory
which again is not going to
fundamentally change things on the
ground whether that gets recognized by
anybody including the united states okay
bottom line is that israel traded
a pledge not to annex which is basically
nothing they basically said to the uae
it was it's a fig leaf okay that's the
reality
israel granted a fig leaf to the uae the
uae wanted to normalize relations with
israel
they said we need something in return to
make it look like we give a crap about
the palestinian authority which we
actually kind of don't
and israel said okay well we just won't
formally annex all this territory we
know is going to end up in israeli hands
under any peace deal in the future
anyway in the uae is like good done
okay because in reality what this deal
really is about is a mutual defense
alliance against iran that's really what
the deal
is about in a surprise announcement at
the white house after a three-way phone
call with israeli and emirati leaders
mr trump said the deal would lead to
greater cooperation on investment
tourism security technology energy
and other areas while the two countries
moved to allow regular direct passenger
flights
open embassies and trade ambassadors for
the very first time this has been a long
time in the making
now the the political media
the idiots like thomas friedman will
suggest it was just it was a window that
opened and the uae and the israelis took
advantage of
nonsense nonsense they've been
negotiations on this thing for a very
very long time
the uae and israel were warming in
relations for at least the last several
years and that was specifically due to
the backlash
to the iranian regime that was created
by barack obama being a full-on
cow tower to the iranian mullahs if
fulfilled the pac would make the
emirates only the third arab country to
have normal diplomatic relations with
israel along with egypt which signed a
peace treaty in 1979
and jordan which signed a treaty in
1994.
president trump announced the deal
yesterday here is what president trump
had to say
this is a truly historic moment not
since
the israel-jordan peace treaty was
signed
more than 25 years ago has so much
progress been made towards peace in the
middle east
by uniting two of america's closest and
most capable partners in the region
something which said could not be done
this deal is a significant step
towards building a more peaceful secure
and prosperous
middle east by the way it's it is also
apparent that oman and bahrain are going
to follow uae in normalizing israeli
ties and saudi arabia cannot be far
behind so this means a complete opening
of the middle east in many
many ways it is a very very good day for
peace in the middle east
now that is not stopping people who hate
peace from being very very angry about
this of course the palestinians have
decided they are going to
withdraw their embassy from the uae to
which the uae is like what do we care
you guys are supported by iran
and good luck to you enjoy yourselves
delany
a member of the plo the palestine
liberation organization's executive
committee remember that's a terrorist
group
said in an interview shortly before the
palestinian ambassador to the emirates
was recalled in protest
this agreement is a total departure from
the arab consensus the palestinian
people have not authorized anyone to
make concessions to israel in exchange
for anything
to which the uae says well good news we
don't give a crap because
we're not the palestinian government we
are the government of the uae
to which the egyptians say right and we
have to secure our border against
palestinian terrorism
to which jordan is like um yeah so and
saudi's like um why would we give a crap
you guys are taking money from the
iranians to pursue terrorism
israel and the emirates have long
maintained a thinly veiled secret
relationship over mutual interest
the idea of formalizing it has come up
several times in the past year
the two sides essentially took it into
the open after six weeks of indirect
talks through jared kushner here was
jared kushner the much-maligned
jared kushner ripped up and down as
adult how could he do anything in the
middle east the stupid trump piece plan
jared kushner doesn't know anything we
need experts like susan rice and the
barack obama anti-israel
super team to go in there and cram down
a deal on israel here's jared kushner
announcing the deal yesterday smarter
than any of these adults here was
kushner yesterday
the president takes untraditional
approaches he does things in different
ways
but he uses common sense and he tries to
unite people
by focusing on common interests as
opposed to allowing them to focus on
their common grievances
and what happened was here is we were
able to achieve results that others were
not able to achieve
and this will advance the region and
this will advance the whole world
i would like to say to the people of the
region muslims jews christians
that this does give hope that the
problems of the past do not condemn you
to
a future with conflict a hundred percent
this is exactly right why because the
deal again
was predicated on the notion that the
united states was going to back israel's
claims to defend itself that israel is
not going away that hopes that israel
will go away
using the palestinians as as a as a
sort of tip of the spear in destroying
israel that those are foolhardy hopes
they are dumb and that economic
relations provide a better way out for
many nations in the middle east
than simple continuation of religious
warfare okay so
this is what happens when you take a
proper relationship to the middle east
non-anti-israel
view toward the middle east peace breaks
out when you say that israel will
continue to remain
and will never go away and that israel
has a right to defend itself
when you don't undercut israel peace
becomes more possible not the opposite
the view of the left has always been if
you undercut israel then the arabs will
be more likely to make peace that is
such a lie
it is such a lie when you undercut
israel what that leads to is the belief
that simply taking an intransigent line
against israel lead to more concessions
by israel
by the way that's a rational response by
arab states that be a rational response
by the palestinian leadership
the more that america forces israel to
make concessions and the more
intransigence the palestinians display
which leads the left to make more
concessions why would you ever make a
peace deal ever
instead you will simply continue to
pursue terrorism by saying
no peace for peace not land for peace
it's not up to israel to make
concessions it's up to you to recognize
that israel is not going away and then
later you can work out
all of the territorial issues that you
got on the table but the reality is you
first have to normalize relations you
first have to recognize realities on the
ground
reality is a good basis for a peace deal
fantasy garbage
pushed by the obama administration is
actually a bad basis for a peace deal
and you can tell that it's a good deal
based on who opposes it
we'll get to who opposes the deal in
just one second by the way
bibi netanyahu the prime minister of
israel said this is historic evening
today a new era begins in the relations
of the state of israel
with the arab world he tweeted out this
is the greatest advancement toward peace
between israel and the arab world
in the last 26 years it marks the third
formal peace agreement between israel
and an arab nation so there's the story
that is going to be told by the press
which is that this is all about israel
foregoing annexation and then there's
the real story which is this is all
about an anti-iranian alliance and a
recognition of realities on the ground
and that's the real story so don't
believe the press's lies that this is
all about
israel's willingness to make concessions
that is not what happened here okay in
the la
we've been told that only if israel gave
up the golan heights gave up east
jerusalem gave up settlements
and pledged to go back to the green line
would there be any sort of surrounding
peace in the middle east and outside in
peace where other nations made peace
with israel
israel annexed the golan heights claimed
the golan heights
has not given up a single settlement and
has
not pledged to do so by the way and is
never giving up east jerusalem and
outside nations are not making peace
with israel so it turns out that all of
the conventional wisdom is a bunch of
crap and it always was a bunch of crap
we'll get to the enemies of this peace
deal and you can call them enemies of
peace because they are literally enemies
of a peace deal we're gonna get to that
in just one second first
you hear stories in the news in which a
good guy uses a gun to protect his
family from criminals and then he
is the one who is arrested the legal
system is not fair a responsibly armed
american may often become a political
target we saw this in st louis
where there were a couple of homeowners
who walked out front to protect their
property from people who had broken into
a private gated community
and then the prosecutor tried to
prosecute them it's not right for good
responsible americans to wind up in jail
or embroiled in a lawsuit for defending
themselves or their family
in this day and age you need a gun to
protect your family and yourself here's
how you can take a simple powerful
journey to firearms and self-defense
confidence
it's called the complete concealed carry
and family defense guide from the united
states concealed carry association it is
free you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting the safest and
most dangerous places to sit in a
restaurant how to responsibly own and
store a gun especially if you have
little kids
and a whole lot more it's 164 pages it
comes with a bonus audio version so you
can listen whenever you want
just text ben to 87222 to get this
indispensable guy text ben to 87222
you'll get instant access and a chance
to win a thousand bucks so you can buy a
gun to protect your family
in a legal fashion text ben to 87 222
right now again tech spend to 87
222 and join my friends over at the us
concealed carry
association right now tech spend 287
222. so who opposes the deal well
iran hates the deal turkey hates the
deal
which is not a shock iran is of course
run by radical
islamic terrorists turkey is run by an
islamist
erdogan who has transformed what was
once a democracy into a thriving hotbed
of islamism
the historic uae israel deal brokered by
the united states considered a major
foreign policy triumph would make uae
the third arab country behind egypt and
jordan to establish full diplomatic
relations with israel but
iran is very very mad according to fox
news iran's foreign ministry called the
agreement a dagger that was unjustly
stuck by the uae and the backs of the
palestinian people
and all muslims see if you're going to
talk about daggers stuck in the back of
muslims you probably have to go with you
know the hundreds of thousands of people
murdered in syria with the help of the
iranians or perhaps the complete
destruction of lebanon
at the behest of iranian-backed
hezbollah maybe you'd have to go with
the
complete breakdown in in yemen with the
houthis
backed by iran creating the problem
there are lots of things you could talk
about when you talk about muslims being
murdered
the uae making a deal with israel that
is not even that's not even the top 200
problems for muslims in the middle east
in fact it's a solution for a lot of
muslims in the middle east
meanwhile the turkish foreign ministry
claimed the uae had no right to
negotiate the deal on behalf of the
palestinians they didn't negotiate any
deal on behalf of the palestinians they
negotiated a deal on behalf of the uae
so the fact that iran and turkey hate it
means it's a good deal
inherently that means it's a good deal
who else was angry about this
well ben rhodes the ridiculous
failed novelist national security
adviser
to president obama whose claim to middle
eastern knowledge was predicated on
sitting
in a in an apartment in brooklyn writing
bad fiction while watching a bum piss
into a trash can
that guy he uh he had some words he says
this agreement enshrines what has been
the emerging status quo in the region
for a long time
including the total exclusion of
palestinians dressed up as an election
of achievement from two leaders who want
trump to win
so in other words this is not a triumph
it's not a good thing
this is the exclusion of the
palestinians it's mean it's bad
well what's weird about that is that ben
rhodes while trying to undermine the
deal
is so bad that not even obama's
assistant secretary of state for
democracy and human rights was buying it
tom malinowski he tweeted out there's a
breakthrough deal for israel for peace
and for u.s diplomacy it affirms that
israel has far more to gain from
normalization with the arab states than
from annexation of the west bank
a win-win we can build on again
recognize that the failure to annex
judea and samaria
that does not change a single thing on
the ground it changes zero things on the
ground
it is a fig leaf it is a complete
political fig leaf so that the uae can
pretend that it got a concession from
israel and in reality all that happened
was a normalization of relations that
the uae and israel both wanted in
opposition
to iran rashida talib resident
anti-semite in the american congress
congresswoman who uh who prioritizes
above all else
the the support for uh palestinian
terrorism she tweeted out we won't be
fooled by another trump netanyahu deal
okay it's not a trump netanyahu deal
it's a netanyahu uae deal it's an israel
uae deal like uae doesn't exist
in rashida talib's universe we won't
celebrate netanyahu for not stealing
land he already controls
in exchange for a sweetheart business
deal the heart of the issue has never
been planned formal annexation but
ongoing devastating apartheid
oh really is that what the issue has
always been not the palestinian refusal
to recognize
the existence of the state of israel the
continued education of children to
murder jews as often as possible by the
way
the same day that israel made a deal
with the uae hamas was floating balloons
laden with explosives over the border
that's been their new fun game now you
ask yourself why would they
send colorful balloons laden with
explosives into israel why would they do
that i can't do that much damage
the answer is who's attracted to
balloons guys who's attracted to
balloons
all this right small children because
hamas is evil
hamas has always been evil palestinian
islamic jihad is evil the iranian
government that backs them
is evil the palestinian government that
backs them is evil
but those are the people who are being
backed by large swaths of the american
political left in the second one you get
to the most ridiculous
spin on this thing the most ridiculous
bit on this thing is joe biden trying to
claim credit for it
so again there's this split in sort of
democratic circle some of them are like
it's a terrible deal
it's a terrible deal we hate the deal
because israel actually got something
good
which is really what it comes down to
they don't want israel and the uae and
saudi arabia and egypt and jordan to
normalize relations because they love
iran and they despise israel
there's no other way to read that
because it is good for the region it is
good for economic normalization
at least joe biden is recognizing it's a
good thing but then joe biden's like and
i did it and you have to be absolutely
high on your own farts to believe that
yeah i mean that's that's a crazy
statement that is a crazy statement it's
like bull conor suggesting that he is
responsible for desegregation
like nope pretty certain not the obama
administration was his anti-israel
pro-iran as any administration in
american history
not as any far more than any
administration in american history them
claiming
the basis for an israel uae deal is
patently crazy we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that you need wireless
earbuds these days you're spending an
awful lot of time
with media you're spending an awful lot
of time on the phone many of us are
working
from home you got to be on the phone a
lot you're listening to your favorite
shows you'll see my favorite music
but you don't want to spend a fortune on
wireless earbuds well what you need are
a great pair of wireless earbuds from
raycon
you already know that raycon earbuds
start at about half the price of any
other premium wireless earbuds on the
market
and that they sound just as incredible
as other top audio brands you do know
their newest model the everyday e25
earbuds those are the best ones yet six
hours of playtime at seamless bluetooth
pairing
more bass and more compact design that
gives you a nice noise isolating fit
raycon's wireless earbuds are so
comfortable they are perfect for
conference calls or bingeing podcasts
unlike some of your other wireless
options raycon earbuds they're stylish
and discrete no dangling wires no stems
to scrat distract anyone during video
calls
my favorite thing about my raycons is
that i can customize them to fit my ear
they are not one size if it's all they
come with a little metal card
has a variety of fits on it you can
customize them put them in your ears
they will fit perfectly
now is the time to get the latest and
greatest from raycon get 15
off your order at buy raycon dot com
slash ben that's b
y r ay c o n dot com slash bend by
raycon dot com slash man
for fifteen percent off raycon wireless
earbuds buy raycon dot com
slash man again that's by raycon.com for
off okay so joe biden tried to claim
credit for this which is just patently
crazy
it is nuts man that is crazy towns
here is here's what he said today israel
and the uae have taken a historic step
to bridge the deep divides of the middle
east
the uae is offered to publicly recognize
the state of israel as a welcome brave
badly needed active statesmanship
it is a critical recognition israel is
vibrant integral part of the middle east
that is here to stay
israel can and will be a valued
strategic and economic partner to all
who welcome it
the coming together of israel and arab
states builds on the efforts of multiple
administrations to foster a broader arab
israeli
opening including the efforts of the
obama biden administration to build on
the arab peace initiative
i personally spent time with leaders of
both israel and the uae during our
administration
building the case for cooperation and
broader engagement and the benefits it
could deliver to both nations i am
gratified by today's announcement okay
joe biden trying to claim credit for
this is okay this is
it's crazy okay it is fully fully fully
nuts my favorite here
one of my favorite things is him trying
to claim that it builds on the efforts
of the obama administration to build on
the arab peace initiative
so what the hell is the arab peace
initiative you may recall that the arab
peace initiative if you're if you are
have familiarity with these issues
was a proposal created by the saudi
crown prince abdullah
at the 2002 arab league summit in beirut
it was later endorsed at
a 2007 summit in riyadh it called for
okay among other things full israeli
withdrawal from the golan heights
withdrawal from all of judea and samaria
withdrawal from east jerusalem including
the temple mount and the western wall
okay so he's saying that the focus on
the arab peace initiative led to this
peace deal
how can you tell that he's totally full
of crap so full of crap that his eyes
are turning brown
the way that you can tell that is that
israel did none of those things israel
has annexed the golan heights israel has
not withdrawn from judea and samaria in
fact it's strengthened its presence in
judea and samaria
and israel has not withdrawn from east
jerusalem at all
and has no intention of doing so said
joe biden's like remember that deal that
we pushed that completely failed that
was the basis for this one
no no it was not okay the real reason
that this deal got cut is because of
obama but it's because obama was so
radically anti-israel and pro-iran
that he drove the uae saudi arabia
jordan bahrain oman
into the arms of the israelis in 2014
the obama administration delayed
delivery of hellfire missiles to israel
is while israel is trying to defend
itself
from the gaza strip and terrorism from
hamas obama was so anti-israel that he
signed an
iranian peace deal that didn't create
peace that only effectuated their
pursuit of a nuclear weapon after 10
years
and gave them full ability to normalize
their economic relations with the rest
of the world and use the money for
terrorism
fully acknowledged by the way by
secretary of state john kerry obama was
so anti-israel that as he was leaving
office he planted a time bomb at the
united nations
passing a u.n security council
resolution and abstaining the security
council resolution
declared that all of judea and samaria
and east jerusalem
were not jewish territory and that there
was no historic tie
okay that's that as a matter of
international law israel has no claim to
the western wall temple mount
the entire jewish quarter of jerusalem
and that they belong to the palestinians
that's how anti-israel obama was
and so now we're hearing from biden that
he's going to take credit for the deal
the man's a damned liar he's a damned
liar and the attempt by the media to
create several competing myths so they
can
continue to pursue their overall myth
which is that pressure on israel creates
peace
they have a few myths that they're
prepaying one obama had anything to do
with that he did not
in fact it's an unintended consequence
of his garbage foreign policy two the
pressure on israel results in peace
that's not a result in peace here there
was no pressure on israel and peace
emerged because
there was no pressure on israel not in
spite of because there was no pressure
on israel
three there's nothing peace in the
middle east is not reliant in any way
on israel making concessions to the
palestinians in any way
and finally that democrats and the
foreign policy establishment
foreign policy establishment know what
in the hell they're talking about they
absolutely do not
national security adviser rob o'brien
said that trump should be up for a nobel
peace prize
okay that is true he should be okay if
obama had cut the steel he would be
here is robert o'brien it's really
remarkable i think when you when you
step back and take a look at what this
president has done on the peace front
uh and and it wouldn't surprise me it'll
take some time in this environment
but it wouldn't surprise me uh if the
president's eventually nominated for a
nobel prize
for the time that this today's work is
an example
uh of why he would be uh uh rightly
considered and should be a front-runner
for the nobel peace prize okay people
are laughing at that
he's done more for peace in the middle
east than anything obama did obama was a
horrible president for the middle east
he set the middle east on fire
and how many regime changes happened
while barack obama was president that
resulted in more dictatorship not less
how much violence broke out in the
middle east while obama was president
okay that guy won the nobel peace prize
for existing trump they all laugh at him
his middle eastern policy has been more
successful than any president of my
lifetime
it is not particularly close by the way
okay meanwhile
all of this is the basis for a solid
trump campaign
here this is always the gap for
president trump his achievements
in many areas are quite good the economy
was stellar up until covet hit
president trump has appointed a lot of
great conservative judges and some who
are not so great to the supreme court
the president of the united states has
has cut some regulations
he cut taxes which is a good thing on
foreign policy he's been significantly
better than any of his predecessors in
the middle east and it's not close
he's been harsher on china than any of
his predecessors and it's not
particularly close
okay all of that is good stuff so why
isn't he doing better in the polls well
there's a pull out today and it shows
exactly why and what he needs to do
to come back in this election plus we'll
get to joe biden and his central pitch
which is kovid it's always going to be
covered we're gonna get to that in just
one second first
let us talk about a great watch that you
can get without breaking the bank i'm
talking about vincero check out this
watch this is a really really
nice looking watch i'm a huge fan of
luxury watches but luxury watches will
cost you thousands and thousands of
dollars how about something that looks
like a luxury watch and ain't gonna cost
you like a luxury watch i'm talking
about this vincero vincero
is giving you a big sale alert you
already know how i feel about vincero
watches
these are great watches they're stunning
they are priced well under 200
these timepieces really do stand out
vincero watches they're dedicated to the
craft they put the time and effort into
create
creating timepieces so you can wear them
day after day right now
vincero is running a site wide sale to
celebrate their sixth anniversary up to
off site wide no code required your
discount will be automatically applied
to check out when you visit
venturawatches.com shapiro everything on
site is on sale no exclusions
including all four of their all new
collections all of those are available
they're shipping all orders directly
from local us distributors they're
delivering all orders on time
no delays they want to get your product
to you as quickly as possible
with vincero no brand name markup no
big-time price tags their promise is
simple
solid well-made products you will enjoy
wearing i enjoy wearing a vincero
venture offers free shipping 30-day
returns guarantees your watch
for two years so it's not gonna fall
apart on you go to v-i-n-c-e-r-o watches
dot com
forward shapiro that is vincero watches
dot com forward slash shapiro for that
special deal
again 30 off do not pay full price on
these amazing time pieces take advantage
of the opportunity vincerowatches.com
forward slash shapiro alrighty it is
that glorious time of the week when i
give a shout out to a daily wire
subscriber today
is william sindelar on instagram who
knows that parents must lead by example
in the picture
william is taking a big swig out of the
world's most elite beverage vessel while
his young daughter
looks on adoringly the caption reads
breakfast of champions hashtag leftist's
tears tumblr hashtag real daily wear
hashtag
proud daughter indeed left is tea
leftist tears are indeed the most
nutritious part of
the food pyramid thanks for the picture
and thanks for being
a daily wire remember you are listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so president trump has actually
done very very many good things as
president of the united states so why
isn't he more popular
the answer is perfectly obvious people
don't like him personally that is a
perfectly obvious answer it's a
perfectly obvious truth which means that
if you can just cut it out
and we all know what it is then he'll
have a good shot at winning okay the
reason that i say this is the case that
nobody is voting for biden based on
policy nobody's voting for biden because
they like his agenda nobody's even
voting for biden because they like biden
they're just voting for bidens they
don't like trump pew research center
poll okay here are the top reasons for
supporting donald trump
23 say leadership performance 21 say his
issue
or policy positions 19 say he is not
biden 17
he's four americans 16 vote for
republicans and against democrats
11 he tells it like it is his
personality so only 11
of people voting for trump are doing it
because they like his personality
okay by contrast joe biden 56
56 of people who are voting for joe
biden say they are voting for joe biden
because quote he is not trump
that's literally the only reason people
are voting for biden there is not
another statistic that breaks 20 percent
leadership or performance only 19 say
leadership or performance
his personality and temperament only 13
say that only nine percent of joe biden
voters say they are voting for him
because of his his issue and policy
positions and only seven percent say
they are doing so because they're
democrats and voting against republicans
so in other words this entire election
has been a referendum on donald trump's
personality
and that continues to be the main factor
militating against a president trump
victory which is something that
president trump should take under
advisement
because that's something he can correct
for stay on the teleprompter
stay on the teleprompter and because on
the issues
the american people do not like the
biden heroes ticket they don't
and now yesterday joe biden and kamala
harris held the press conference at
which they
answered zero questions that was
exciting so they're just going to
continue to maintain because they
understand that the media
are not here to report the media are
here simply to drool over them and to
rip into president trump so they have a
massive advantage which is they will
never have to answer questions
and joe biden can be wheeled on a gurney
all the way into the oval office
with that said i am absolutely amazed at
the lack of follow-up questioning
from the media on broad-based policies
proposed
by biden and herrera so yesterday they
did this presser that wasn't oppressor
because they answered no questions
in which biden and harris sat six feet
apart awkwardly and talked to experts on
covid
and and then recommended silly things so
here was joe biden yesterday calling for
a national mass mandate for the next
three months
let's talk about this makes zero sense
at all for a couple of reasons
every governor should mandate
every governor should mandate mandatory
mask wearing the estimates by the
experts are will save
over 40 000 lives
in the next three months 40 000 lives
that people act responsibly and uh
it's not about your rights it's about
your responsibilities
as an american okay so he's saying we
need a national mass mandate okay so a
couple of things one he doesn't mean a
national mass mandate there is no
constitutional power
to for the federal government to
actually enact a federal mass mandate
it doesn't exist right and also i'm
amused by folks on the left to keep
saying the national government should
institute a mass mandate
okay who are you going to have enforce
it guys what's your plan you said
federal troops into the cities
so i guess the left agenda on this is
not to protect federal property that's
being burned by antifa in portland
federal troops in the cities to yell at
you if you're not wearing a mask
while jogging okay but that's not even
really what biden is saying he's saying
i think all governors should institute
masked men oh well i'm glad for your
opinion joe
thank you for your useless garbage empty
opinion that means nothing
i'm glad that you think things wow do
you mean as president you're going to
tell governors to do a thing that they
can completely ignore
slow clap wow you solved kova do well
well done kamala hair is like this is
going to save lives this is going to
save
lives okay comma sure
we just witnessed real leadership which
is
joe biden said that as a nation
we should all be wearing a mask for the
next
three months because it will save lives
and the thing about joe that the
american people know
is that his role of leadership in our
country has always been about doing
what's best for the people of our
country
except when he's trying to ban her from
going to an integrated public school
against families
it joe's leadership has always been
great except when he was sexually
harassing the help and or
stopping me from going to an integrated
public school says kamala harris the
most cynical politician uh of the modern
day
i love that that was real leadership
from joe biden did you know that he said
there and said mask he said the word
mask that's leadership
we're done here i mean come on we have
solved covet guys
sure by the way most americans in hot
spots are wearing masks
they're wearing masks without a mask
mandate because most americans
are taking seriously coveted in areas
where kovid is spiking
then biden and harris refused to take
questions which is really exciting stuff
because remember
donald trump has never had to answer a
hard question but these people are
willing to answer all the hard questions
except when they're running directly off
stage so joe biden can go get an oxygen
tank here is here's kamala harris
yesterday
i'm honored to be with you jeff thank
[Music]
you
so president trump by the way unmasks
much more coherent than either kamala
harris or joe biden because he actually
apparently understands the role of the
federal government he said you should
wear a mask but we are not state
governments and it is not the job of the
federal government to force people to
wear masks
accurate okay that's called federalism
it's in the constitution here's
president trump
he wants the president of the united
states with the
mere stroke of a pen to order over 300
million american citizens to wear a mask
for a minimum of three straight months
he does not identify what authority the
president has to issue such a mandate or
how federal law enforcement could
possibly
enforce it or why we would be stepping
on governors throughout our country many
of whom have done a very good job and
they know what
is needed by the way correct by the way
california has mass mandates all over
the place california just became the
first state with over six hundred
thousand diagnosed cases
of covid they have a higher death count
than californ than texas
or florida and the curve has not yet
been under bend really
in california okay so here's the thing
again
when it comes to policy president trump
is not wrong on a lot of this stuff
okay i'm not saying that he's perfect
because no president is perfect
there are a lot of things i disagree
with including his spending policies but
the real problem for trump is not his
policies the real problem for trump is
his running mouth that continues to be
the real problem for president trump
i'll give you a couple of examples okay
so yesterday during a press conference
president trump
was asked about this column from john
eastman who's a law professor
uh over at claremont institute he's
written a lot um
and uh and he wrote a column basically
suggesting that maybe kamala harris was
not eligible for the presidency that's
because
his interpretation of the 14th amendment
is that in order to become a citizen
you have to have been you have to have
been naturalized
in other words he doesn't believe in the
in the idea that if you're born in the
united states you're a natural born
citizen and so he asks whether kamala
harris's parents ever became
naturalized citizens there are questions
about that therefore the fact that she
was born in the united states does not
naturally make her a citizen that's his
legal theory it's not accepted by
virtually anybody
virtually everybody understands that
kamala harris is a natural born citizen
of the united states
she was literally born here her parents
apparently were
naturalized as best we know and so
there's not a lot of credence to that
president trump throwing out this theory
is completely useless and
counterproductive because again the case
against kamala harris is not her
ineligibility the case against kamala
harris is that she's awful
that she's awful so why does the
president constantly stick his hand in
beehives
and yesterday was a day where he cut a
historic middle east peace deal the
biggest middle east peace deal in 30
years
and today when the democrats decided to
go full on
top down control on masks and here he
was talking about kamala harris's
eligibility for the vice presidency come
on come
on this is useless
i heard it today that she doesn't meet
the requirements
and by the way the lawyer that wrote
that piece is a very highly qualified
very talented
lawyer i have no idea if that's right i
would have thought i would have assumed
the democrats would have checked that
out before she gets chosen to run for
vice president
but that's a very serious you you're
saying that they're saying that she
doesn't qualify because she wasn't born
in this country
okay so you know that's that come on
come on
how is that useful in any way speaking
of things that are not useful in any way
yesterday president trump was talking
about defunding the post office so
there's been a lot of talk about whether
to pour more
money down the rat hole that is the post
office the post office is
awfully run it has been awfully run for
years because the post office's mandate
is to ensure that if you're in a
far-flung area you get charged the same
postage as if you are in like a major
american city
they run at a loss the post office has
run at a loss for years which is why
fedex continues to be more reliable
and if you really want to make sure the
mail gets there on time you don't use
the post office at all
right so the case that republicans have
been making about the post office is why
are we
why are we spending more money on the
post office when less mail is now being
sent
then ever before in american history why
are we doing that
that makes no sense at all right that
was the republican case that the
democrats were trying to
pour more money into the post office
because the giant government boondoggles
so why are we pouring more billions of
money
more billions of dollars into the post
office president trump then goes on
national tv
and he says the reason we should defund
the post office is that the post office
does not have the wherewithal to handle
mail and voting
why why god why why
why why well hey why why why
again the point of not funding the post
office that is a bad servicing got to
fix it first
it is not anything to do with mail-in
voting
okay the problem with mail and voting is
that the us postal service is not going
to be able to get the mail there on time
that universal mail and voting people
keep saying absentee ballots are the
same as mail in voting they're not the
same as universal mail in voting
universal mail in voting is they send a
ballot directly to your house
before you even ask for one they do so
on a universal level it doesn't matter
if you've already moved you might be
receiving three four ballots at your
house right it opens the door
wide to people committing fraud it does
and just because
not a lot of people have taken advantage
of that doesn't mean you should loosen
the laws
or you should make it easier that is the
point on universal mail in voting
absentee ballots you request because you
can't make it to the polling station for
example
democrats are pushing universal mail and
voting this year on the back of the
pandemic but the suspicion is the real
reason they are doing that
is because they wish to have universal
mail and voting and ballot harvesting so
they can deploy
democratic operatives to go house to
house and pick up ballots on behalf of
democrats which is exactly what they did
in orange county california during the
2018 election
and shifted four red seats blue okay so
that is the objection to universal mail
and voting that is not an objection to
funding the postal service so people
can't actually send in anything
including absentee ballots heroes trump
shooting himself directly in the foot
yesterday
they won three and a half trillion
billion dollars
for the mail-in votes okay universal
mail and ballots
three and after they want 25 billion
dollars
billion for the post office now they
need that money in order to have the
post office work so it can take all of
these millions and millions of ballots
now in the meantime they aren't getting
there
by the way those are just two items but
if they don't get those two items that
means you can't have universal
mail-in voting because they're not
equipped to have it okay so now he's
saying that he's going to deprive the
post office of resources so the mail and
voting won't work that like
why why that just opens the door it's
joe biden's saying that trump's trying
to undermine electoral
integrity which is exactly what biden
stumbles over himself but says here's
joe biden yesterday
come on guys
what do you think about that pure trump
okay guys let's go let's go fun election
he doesn't want an election is what joe
biden says that's the that's the idea
that
so again if president trump wants to win
the election he's gonna need to get out
of his own way
now obviously the media aren't gonna
help here right the media are
being fated as heroes for massaging the
massaging the shoulders of the biden
harris campaign while simultaneously
just
trying to make a name for himself
yelling at trump yesterday a huffington
post reporter
got up at a press conference and just
started haranguing trump which of course
is not
asking a question it's just him being a
jerk but don't worry he'll get a jim
acosta book contract next
mr president after three and a half
years you regretted
all all the lying you've done to the
american people
all the lying all the dishonesties that
who has done
you have done uh tensorflow go ahead
please
and then you just ignored him okay but
the media were like wow look at the
heroism so much harrowing oh heroing
media are garbage trump needs to
understand the media are garbage he
needs to not give them
any sort of ammo deprive the enemy of
ammunition is one of the electoral
strategies trump must pursue if he
wishes to win okay now
i wanna make a quick comment comment on
a story that is finally getting some
national attention so there's a story
that got no national attention for like
a week and uh my compatriot here at
daily wire matt walsh really pushed it
into the mainstream
it's a story of a 25 year old man a
black man
who shot a five-year-old boy last week
in wilson north carolina he's now been
charged with first-degree murder
austin hinand told cnn affiliate wral he
was inside the home when his son cannon
was playing outside and was shot hence
as he ran outside and scooped up the
injured child and held him in his arms
i screamed somebody help me please help
me save my son and then told the
affiliate he looked up and saw his
neighbor
darius sessoms in the yard next door
with a gun in his hand pacing and
frantic
i was looking at him as i was picking up
cannon i was so full of rage but i
couldn't leave my son's side i just want
to be
with my son hen's fiance called 9-1-1
sessoms then drove away
police identified him as a suspect
arrested him after he was found monday
in a goldsboro residence about 30
minutes
south okay so the motive is not yet
clear the point that matt walsh was
making is that if the races were
reversed there is no question it would
be a national story
now do i actually think that this should
be a national story i actually don't
think it should be a national story i
think it's a local crime story i think
it's horrific
i think it's an act of tremendous evil
the only reason that it should in any
way be
a national story is because the media
have a double standard on what
constitutes a national story and this is
worthy of comment
okay the ahmedabary story should not be
a national story it is a local crime
story
what it becomes a national story all
stories are initially local
what becomes a national story is one of
two things either a story that affects
the entire nation or
a story that is indicative of a broader
trend plaguing the entire nation
there's not a broad trend in the united
states of white people hunting down
black people
which is why the ahmed arberry story
should not be a national story it is an
oddity and a local crime story
and a horrific horrific story it should
not be a national crime story
neither should michael brown neither
really should george floyd because there
is not a great spate of white cops
murdering black
black people it's just not happening
none of those should be national stories
they should all be local crime stories
the same thing holds true here there is
not a spate of black people killing
five-year-old white children so that
really should not be a national news
story either
the only reason that it should be
treated as a national news story is
simply as a slap in the face to a media
that have decided that certain
narratives are worthy of promulgation
and other narratives are not
and so if the media wants to pretend
that any horrific crime story is now a
national news story then they do need to
cover
the canon hinnon story and if they want
to claim that interracial crime
is a national news story then they need
to cover it in a statistically
representative way
in a statistically representative way on
a on a population adjusted level
more white people are killed by black
people in the united states than black
people are killed by white people in the
united states now the reason that's not
a national news story either way
is because the vast majority of white
people like vast vast like 90
95 like a huge percentage of white
people who are killed are killed by
other white people
the same thing is true for black people
killing other black people so if you
actually wanted
stories that are representative of broad
national trends what you would focus on
are five-year-olds being shot in the
inner city in gang warfare that's more
indicative of a national trend that
requires national attention
right that would be something worthy of
national coverage or a white person
killing another white person in an
opioid addicted town right that would be
more indicative of a national news story
but our national news coverage is skewed
toward particular narratives that's the
point that matt walsh is making so do i
actually think that this canon hidden
story is deserving of quote-unquote
national attention
probably not it's a local news story
it's deserving of attention just because
of human tragedy but that's not really
why people want it to be covered
and exacerbating racial tensions by
claiming that certain stories are
indicative of trends that do not exist
on either side
is a mistake okay so later today we have
two additional hours
of commentary and content i still have a
lot to get to including by the way
the fact that hbo max is now putting a
disclaimer on blazing saddles
they're putting a disclaimer on blazing
saddles an intro to ensure that the film
is put into proper social context
the proper social context by the way is
that people didn't used to be jack
wagons
who wouldn't laugh at jokes that's the
proper social context is that you
yourself if you need a proper social
context for blazing saddles it's because
you're an uptight prude
and this coming from a guy who just got
excoriated for reading lyrics on the air
okay get over yourselves okay we'll see
you here a little bit later today
otherwise we'll see you here on monday
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about
i hope you'll give it a listen
you